okay welcome to chess of the 21st
century our player today is drumroll and
that's the quite a drumroll ever let's
see is that who's the guy with one arm
Def Leppard guy so be quiet drumroll
cause it's one anyway it's gonna be
charissa yep whose pictures on the wall
outside there
she's 12 ish 13 ish this she's 12 but
she'll be 13 later I guarantee it
okay and I've known Karissa for years
because I coach at the World Youth every
year and she's always winning medals and
getting close to winning medals if not
winning medals and if I'm correct which
I'm not I think she's already won two
medals in the World Youth over the last
three years
her USCF rating is approximately twenty
three forty and so that's pretty good in
the last month and a half
she's won rated games against
grandmasters two of them so that's also
pretty good but Danny could tell the
same kind of stories I don't know he's
not impressed okay so this was a famous
game that she won near the end of the US
Women's Championship against Irina cross
a grandmaster and white was really
winning and now white is making it
interesting and yeah so it's actually
very interesting now many of you at home
will have know this game because you
follow our Chess Club stuff and when
they do the live commentary on the
incident I'm sure you saw Maurice jet
and yes or talk about this position and
you guys are pretty suspicious at home
so I'm guessing with all the stuff you
take you probably forgot so yeah and
people here never knew so we're all good
okay so black is in check and white
wants to make a queen because making a
queen is good however this one also
wants to Queen and the white rook is
hanging and it's pinned so there's a lot
going on here
okay so Irina played
not the best move she played King to g6
if you're taking notes at home making
mistakes is bad okay and when your
opponent's trying to Queen you usually
want to stop them you writing that you'd
write that down
no you just really remember it I don't
know okay well obviously we can't Queen
now because if we play f7 then rook
takes rook check sort of puts a kibosh
on that okay
now the king is pretty close to the pawn
so let's make the King move away from
the pawn yay any one rook g7 okay and
Irene is a grandmaster so she made the
best move here people at home were like
I don't get it okay King age six the
only legal move okay so that's pretty
forced and now White's rook is hanging
and it's pinned you agree so the obvious
move is h1 yeah and black takes okay and
actually white only has one move that
wins in this position and it's the kind
of move when you're 12 or 13 years old
and you're a master then you get your
dream because it's all tricks and
tactics okay
so the technique wasn't great but the
finish is great because it sort of had
to be in here well black has a lot of
counter play black has a passed pawn the
bishops coming to stop the pawn the
White King is nowhere to be seen and we
can't push our pawn now because the rook
is hanging if we move our rook Black has
time to play Bishop d5 and stop the pawn
and then get her own pawn going and the
bishop controls the queening square so
this is what I read it was hoping for
when she played King g6 the computer
told us who was winning we're doing live
commentary Alejandro and I and I was
like I guarantee she'll find it because
this is you know now if you get somebody
like I don't know Alex Marlar all right
old doesn't play a lot not very no
you're not finding this move okay Alex
Marla's like I don't know a rook here
and then and then after Bishop takes
rook f7 King g7 No
however Marlar having seen the game
knows the right move is Karissa yep
Irina crush
ah she played the only winning move
which the class remember rug g5 the
truth hurts highest rated player in the
room is impressed yeah it stops Bishop
d5 - yeah yeah hey when that happens you
want to play Bishop g5 and they stop it
yeah now if you take the rook the pawn
Queens with an extra Queen 2300 they're
pretty good you guys I don't know but
okay and wrote g5 was played pretty
quickly cuz you know that's that's what
she dreams of his tricky moves like that
Rug g5 and I would definitely not resign
because I don't resign I don't like bees
like I would take and push my H pawn and
I'd lose in a few hours okay but but she
resigned yeah so that was a very nice
win and it was her second win in a month
over a grandmaster and it basically put
irene out of the contesting the first
place for the tournament and then it was
just pot kids Ian hot tub after this
game okay next I'm done yeah it's from
last month
wow this is all crazy okay now this game
was very suspicious we're not gonna look
at the beginning of the game because we
might lose some of our audience now
usually when juniors are playing and
they're really high rated there's really
interesting brilliant middle games than
the endgame technique doesn't make any
sense
this was the opposite this game White
was not losing and then White was
probably winning but then things turned
around and they got to a drawn ending
but white made a mistake on her last
move
she played King to f3 okay and then g4
so when the King was not on f3 white
should have played g4 and then after H
takes G she could have played King to g3
and that would be a draw so two moons
ago g4 was drawing but instead white
played King f3 and now when white played
g4 black is actually winning and black
found the only move to win like a
million moves in a row so I guess that's
how you get to become a master you play
the right move every move and usually
that's very difficult
not because chess is easy or hard but
because
you're tired it's like three four or
five hours into the game and you've been
thinking a lot at the end of the game
sometimes people don't play as well
because they're exhausted and here black
only has one move that wins following
one of my rules in the endgame you
should always do this
you should always play King to e6 very
specific rule now the rule of the
endgame is always move your King up in
the endgame also never trade so HG is
bad because it trades also it's a dead
draw that my King takes an h5 and King
e6 movie your king up actually wins and
that's the only winning move and she
played it and Wow if white had played g4
instead of playing King f3 black King
wouldn't have been in the sector to do
that so okay so f5 check to make it as
tricky as possible white wants to have
no pawns on the board okay then
now if white plays normally like I don't
know it takes and and King e for now f5
looks pretty good if only it was her
turn and black plays the winning move
yeah Knight c3 and then you're you're
not gonna play a five then you got
nothing okay so since taking Keaney 4
doesn't work
King e4 right away obviously doesn't
work because of num yum-yum okay so f5
check that's the trickiest
so how do we win wish I knew yeah the
otherwise you lose all your puns right
he need pawns to win ok GF 5 G takes h 5
so whites hoping I'm gonna go here
you're gonna go there and then I'm gonna
go when your pawn and draw her a good
plan right so for example king takes e5
h6 King f6 h7 King g7 king f4 drop right
easy okay so the King has to save this
pawn and the King has to stop this pawn
maybe this night should be doing
something yeah Knights not doing
anything so you're not going to win if
you lose you're offline now in these
endings assuming you're not an advanced
player you're not going to win if this
pawns off the board I mean I would win
but we're not going to talk about that
okay
because I know how to meet with a knight
but yeah you need a pawn to win and you
have to keep your pawn what's funny is
if you're playing like a blitz game or a
rapid game you could go too far and in a
drawn position I have to keep my pawn
than your opponent starts quitting both
of their pawns so actually black has to
be careful because like if we start this
maybe this one's gonna Queen
maybe White's gonna have the advantage
okay so charisa played knight to be for
King III and the reason for walking III
silly but the idea is I'm gonna play
Knight takes e5 check so I can play
Knight c6 or 93 and then the good player
is always lucky yeah there we go yeah
now we're not so concerned okay and also
we're not even concerned with that
that's illegal
yeah okay so that Knight is doing a
pretty good job white played King white
played King III King takes e5 because
now the Kings on e3 so we have night
Chuck and yeah and black wins if you're
rooting for black and that's the verse
we're talking about in the lecture and
well it was fine during the US
Championship
I explained to Fabio
Caruana didn't play a lot in the US
before he came back and said people here
don't resign so don't be offended and
then a lot of his opponents didn't
resign there was a lot of extra moves
played in some of these games yeah okay
and the women's championship they
resigned probably even later than the
championship were they still not
resigning and it was funny one of the
games I thought the guy resigned in the
right position like so he's like that
was very insulting what he did and I was
like what they thought he liked a game I
didn't think a guy played on too long my
friends thought he played on too long
and I got okay I never think it's
insulting not to resign I don't I don't
like resigning okay next we have a
really funny game from the championship
this is Chris's white against a cheetah
Gordy so white was winning winning
winning winning winning winning winning
everything won great technique
everything was fine and then something
funny happened which is good for the
spectators okay so charissa after Bishop
h5 she's like the ship h5 I'm gonna make
a queen now after the game I assumed
that she just didn't see blacks threat
and I asked her she's like I didn't see
that okay because sometimes when people
are winning they play too quickly so
basically every move wins and if it's
black smooth then White's winning
because black actually doesn't have a
threat here but white hooked her up
gotta give your opponent some help right
okay so white was like there's no threat
and she's right there is no threat but
she played d7 to Queen and now there is
a threat so the idea is Bishop f3 of the
obvious move runs into Queen f5 check
and then white plays Queen takes bishop
so she wasn't worried about Bishop f3
and there's nothing else to worry about
so at g7 and and well nobody should've
f3 there's no Queen f5 check anymore so
this is actually very funny we have
computers running so we know that
White's winning but we also know that
nobody would win like that so we're like
did she see Bishop f3 and I'm like now
and she's still winning she it's almost
you resign you're with White Queen G to
me so the any move is like
12 Queen e6 and Knight d5 and anything
but after this why it's really lucky
that she's winning the white actually
still is winning and white played yeah
and Queen h8 actually isn't accurate but
it's fine
it's just it repeats so I like it
because now you go here Queen Queen giad
is actually more accurate but now we
transpose so actually if you don't play
Queen GA you can't win but I can play
Queen GA later
so Queen eh eh it's actually very funny
so obviously if you take the Queen I
Queen and I play Queen d3 check and I
take your bishop okay so she didn't take
the Queen she played King to g6 and
she's still threatening me and now you
you have to play King h7 because if you
move your king other squares for example
f6 or f5 i I win your Bishop yeah and
this is the same I forgot if this is the
quickest win or this is I think but also
94 check wins yeah what's that
or you can throw it with Jack every move
wins so she has to go back to h7 so what
is the Queen H a king g6 draw no now she
found Queen g8 again you can't take the
Queen for the same reason there's you
but you keep but now if you play King to
G that she did take if you play King to
g6 I go here and again if you go to g5
as the crowd pointed out queening with
check is good and now that's it in fact
I don't take the bishop because I can
meet you okay so after Queen's g8 she
has to take it and now King age 7 falls
into queen d3 check so king f7 Queen d7
Shaq you can't go to FA because the
Queen f5 check so you have to go either
lots of one of these squares and she
went to g8 check and then Queen f5 check
next move
and king g6 allows queen d3 check
winning the bishop
and king f6 probably loses for more than
one reason
somebody help I need help
my check I take it with a bishop I take
it I take it I guess this one's pretty
easily because I have Queen f4 check
irrespective of what you do right every
legal move I play Queen f4 check and
take your bishop yeah well it's clear
you're gonna lose your bishop there's
like 5 million checks of the bishops
hanging yeah so that so after the game
she was like yeah I didn't see the ship
f3 it's a good thing opti resigned so
the good player is always lucky yeah
yeah cheap late d7 Bishop f3 the
computer still said she is winning and
we're like well you wouldn't win like
that that's crazy then there was a
really one thing at your Bishop f3 right
and some people when the wrong state of
mind would just resign because they're
like what no my mission f3 nah but then
like you calm down in you're winning
yeah so now for her best game which was
against Kovalev played in Philadelphia
she had the white pieces
she played what a V Friedman likes to
call the junior variation because all
juniors play it it's a double King pawn
opening where you sack up on what d4
like the Scotch gambit and they play 300
Musa Fury and white gets no advantage
but they love it they like to play the
300 was a theory
so why got no advantage and then white
outplayed black and blacks made already
one or two mistakes and decided to make
up move the probably loses I think
Bishop c6 is the best to move by Bishop
c4 which is not not good yeah okay and
basically like this ain't doing anything
over here that's just sitting there like
looking good and whites you know gonna
plant like a 13 12 year old master and
checkmate black
so there's AB c6 at least maybe I'll
play d4 and take all your pieces maybe
okay but Bishop c4 I'm not sure what
that's all about
okay so Karissa decided to you know
punch and played rawr the most
aggressive move
five yeah rawr and I guess she blundered
hurry pawn yeah but yeah it's funny this
is already really bad for black okay
taking is a blunder but I mean I mean
this is just terrible why it's gonna
play off six you can't you know come on
yeah this is like a dream for white
white just like a tax and black
selectman I give us that very good
okay so Queenie five is good if it
doesn't lose but it loses and wow the
next move is actually quite nice I think
I'm sure you I'm sure you'd all play it
when I said you would all play anything
anybody would play it so I was right so
far
well Bishop c5 I could play Bishop c5
check I could play queen of d6 Bishop d4
I would play queen to d6 I guess oh wait
maybe I would play pawn takes Bishop and
you'd resign yeah that's even better
yeah then I'm threading pawn I'm
threading pawn takes pawn check yeah
that's what I would do
so this isn't good this isn't good and
maybe white just didn't see the move but
it's hard to believe why it's a pretty
strong grandmaster very good yeah Bishop
g5 yeah now the Queen's attacked and it
has a lot of places to go so I mean as a
human I just play Queen d6 I don't even
play I don't even think of another move
and black didn't do that cuz blacks like
me and that losses and actually the
computer doesn't play Queen d6 either
which I was shocked at but yeah Queen d6
there's a funny variation okay
so we'll play some kind of fork and
you'll trade Queens that go into the
lost ending and then I checkmate you
yeah that's unfortunate
if you don't play Queen h6 let's go here
I don't know then I'm gonna go here and
then I'm gonna play Queen g5 and Richie
3 and yeah a lot of good defense over
there
yeah computer says like +8 for white so
because like this is that's that's not
good unless you have Wyatt then
it's really good so black did a very
strange thing in my opinion I just
wonder if he didn't see Bishop g5 like I
don't know or maybe he saw and he's like
well I can't let white play up sex so
maybe she won't play Bishop g5 and what
a lot of people do when they're
blundering when they play Queen e5 is
they're looking at moves like this ship
takes e5 these sort of the obvious move
and then he's like oh that's okay I take
it which a queen d6 or play queen is
like right away and then moves like this
ship g5 just escape him move that don't
take things well you could take things
so taking this doesn't make any sense
because White's trading off the great
dish up and this Bishop is the words
Bishop ever they can't move and instead
Bishop g5 as recommended by Alex Marlar
he said I've had enough of Bishop g5 and
now yeah you just get checked and now
there's these pieces just aren't they're
not participating in the defense of the
King and whites whites got everything
over there and well that's why the
juniors like this opening it's the
junior opening okay so he played a move
I would never consider rook e8 as we say
in Europe insult
okay so then down a queen Farouk and
then you just keep playing
I would keep playing if that's what I do
I design okay and then yeah Bishop e3
seems good then the rest of the game is
a bit silly King h1 safe the safest move
ever trade off yeah mr. g1 safe yeah and
then she gets back to check reading her
opponent King h1 Bishop g1 reminds me of
like Chomsky and Karpov put together
like always the safest possible you know
which is unusual for a junior like to
play like a solid safe move instead of
now I have six now we're talking yeah
that's that's the way juniors like to
apply it
okay so g6 rook f2 trading the rooks h6
h3 which I would have played an hour ago
threatening Queen takes h6 threatening
in Queen e7 I guess make Queenie seven
looks annoying yeah so okay good
defending it that bond the bishop you
miss review one's a nice move Bishop d2
stops the pawn threatens h6 yeah that's
nice yeah okay I mean I'm in here and I
hear it now here I don't resign but like
I mean okay here I'm not it's hard to
play moves here this is getting silly
yeah yeah teenage seven instead of
resigning well yeah yeah and even black
had his limits here and he was like I
ready to give up so that was a famous
King was it was it a big tournament with
like lots of prize money and lots of
grandmasters and such and she won like
sort of very easily and then she beat a
gram yesterday next tournament here at
the US Women's Championship so that's
very impressive and Karissa want a medal
I think it my that my second was my
first or my second my second world youth
in South Africa if she won the last
round she got gold and she was winning
but then there was time trouble and the
game went all the way to the end like 90
moves and ended up being a draw and
thinks she got the silver of the bronze
I think the bronze and then she got a
medal the last World Youth she played in
let's see where was I in Greece and I
think she got silver yeah and yeah she's
always doing well this is the world
girls under 10 the world goes under 12
and she's one of the top in the world
for her age and I'm guessing mmm
three or four years she'll probably be
one of the top three or four winner in
the US if not sooner than that and we'll
see her winning some of us women's
championships if she continues to play
which we always hope our juniors do and
for those of you who are watching at
home next month were having 2 norm
tournaments here
June 8th 2010 which unfortunately I'm
playing in which I discussed in my last
lecture with roofing Lee from this class
and say I did something interesting I
was looking at people to find for this
lecture and I think born 2001 and later
other than another player who we won't
mention because that's too complicated
for this class roofing lead is probably
the highest rated player in the world
born 2001 later there's somebody higher
but their rating is based on stuff that
we can't talk about the k-factor was 40
and it's they were families the best so
you might be the best player in the
world board in 2001 and later
what's its mark on faith and charissa
yep is one of the top women in the world
born and thinks she's I think she turns
13 in this jar now she already did but
and they did something and so she was
saying to the people at home she's
playing in the I am dorm tournament
social try to get an IM norm next month
she'll be here playing and roofing
leaves playing in my section so if I do
a lecture on you you're gonna come here
and play we're gonna see what's up and
then I'm going to move to Atlanta
cuz that's because that gonna be good
for me here alright so you guys know at
home my prediction last two weeks ago
wasn't good
Toronto did beat Miami and tonight I
predict you guys already know I think
Golden State a wooden game 5 I think ok
sees me win the series the wrap it up at
home and a couple of days which you guys
already know alright good job good job
charissa see you next month and see you
guys next time on the GM in residence
well now